♪♪
-From Rockefeller Center
in the heart of New York City,
it's "The Tonight Show"
starring Jimmy Fallon.
Tonight, join Jimmy
and his guests, Charlize Theron,
Governor Andrew Cuomo,
musical guest
Little Big Town,
and featuring the legendary
Roots crew.
And now,
here's your host, Jimmy Fallon.
♪♪
-Hi, everyone, and welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
As you can see, we are back
in the studio
at 30 Rockefeller Plaza
here in New York City.
And as a New Yorker, I want to
say thank you to everyone
who helped get us back to
where we are now,
wearing masks,
social distancing,
washing hands, quarantining,
it all helps.
And to all the states going
through the tough parts
right now, our friends
in Florida, Arizona,
Texas, California, all over
the South, I know how hard it is
and I'm not gonna lie to you --
it's rough.
But I guess I'm here to show you
that there is a light
at the end of the tunnel
if we all do our part
to keep each other safe.
I don't know if anyone else
feels this way, but normalcy,
any type of normalcy
feels great.
So hopefully we can put a smile
on your face for an hour
every night and let you
sit back and relax
while we try to bring you
just a little bit of normal.
These are the hardest times
to do comedy,
but they're also the times
when we need it the most.
Maybe that's why comedy
was invented.
Hmm.
-Hmm.
-Chew on that.
[ Laughter ]
As you're drifting off to sleep.
Let that marinate for a bit
before you flip it on the grill.
[ Laughter ]
Either way, we here
at "The Tonight Show"
always want to bring you
the best show possible.
And that means having
the safest show possible.
Everyone here in the studio
has tested negative for COVID
and all of our crew are wearing
masks and face shields
and we're all six feet apart.
Take a look.
We are taking this
very seriously.
And I want to thank NBC
for really doing a great job
of making sure everyone here
feels safe.
Just to walk you through my day,
when I got in this morning,
I had a temperature check,
I did the nose swab test,
the one that goes all the way
up into your brain.
Yeah, I didn't know that
at the same time you can get
a COVID test and a colonoscopy,
but, hey, we're learning, right?
Anyway, once I was cleared,
I could go to my office
and get ready for the show.
In every part of the office
is a little slip of paper --
thank you -- saying that
it's been disinfected.
Yeah.
This was truly done
the safety way possible.
Thank you.
And we would only do it that way
if that was the case,
the safety way.
We're thankful to have
the Roots with us tonight.
I'm very happy to see you guys.
I missed you.
Sent a bunch of texts.
[ Laughter ]
Didn't hear back.
The show is gonna be
a little different
than what you're used to.
There is no audience.
The guests will be
streaming from home.
But I think in some ways
we're all kind of
getting used to different.
But what we want you to know
is that we are here for you
and we are slowly and safely
getting back to work
and back to whatever normal is.
So welcome again to "The Tonight
Show" and thanks for watching.